our final exciting hour begins with
chris rock
jada i love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to
see
wow
wow
the moment that stunned audiences and
viewers worldwide will smith is smacked
out of it
the joke that some found distasteful as
jada suffers from alopecia a condition
that causes hair loss seems to have been
the last straw for will as chris rock
also made a joke at will's wife's
expense during the 2016 oscars keep my
wife's name out your
mouth wow dude
yeah it was a gi jane jump keep my
wife's name out
now i'm going to okay
leaving the crowd speechless like lupita
nyong'o bradley cooper was spotted
talking to will shortly after the
altercation giving each other a hug and
during commercial break denzel
washington and tyler perry were by
will's side
on twitter will and jada's son jaden
seemingly shares his reaction simply
tweeting and that's how we do it ahead
of the incident will posted a video to
instagram writing that him and jada were
dressed up to choose chaos hours later
he commented on his own post writing you
can't invite people from philly or
baltimore nowhere over at the annual
elton john aids foundation party the
reactions kept coming sometimes we have
moments that we're not proud of and you
know it happens so let's move on
everybody was just silent and looking
around like did that that really
happened
and during the vanity fair oscars party
tiffany haddish had this to say i wish i
had a man to protect me like that
while on cbs this morning gayle king
reveals she has a heavy heart i went to
bed with such deep sadness i woke up
with deep sadness as well
despite the emotional altercation will
went on to win for best actor for his
film king richard denzel said to me a
few minutes ago he said at your highest
moment
be careful that's when the devil comes
for you
i want to apologize to the academy i
want to apologize to all my fellow
nominees
shortly after the academy issued a
statement online writing they do not
condone violence of any form and in new
reports today will could potentially
lose his oscar over breaking the
academy's code of conduct but academy
governor whoopi goldberg said otherwise
on the view today we're not going to
take that oscar from him well we're not
going to take your consequences too well
there will be consequences i'm sure but
i don't think that that's what they'll
well
now we have yet to hear from chris
publicly but the actress declined to
file a police report according to the
lapd and page six spoke with rapper sean
diddy combs at the vanity fair party and
he claims the two have already made
amends judging by these photos the
incident did not put a damper on will
and his family's night as they
celebrated his first oscar while singing
and dancing to his hit getting jiggy
with it at the same party